[Music]
jake
starts us off in garden city kansas hey
jake how are you
i'm better than i deserve jay how about
yourself just the same sir
just the same how can we help i
am 24 years young and i've done a lot of
dumb in my life
i'm a mechanic i've i got a question on
on if i'm doing the right thing here
i've got uh
20 almost 22 thousand dollars in debt on
my tools um
which i have to have to do my job so i'm
paying that off as quick as i can
uh i'm in a place right now that my
house i have two offers on it for
to where i can get out and get a fair
amount of
equity out of it right now i'm paying
on it and i'm paying the pmi on it and
all that and i'm on a 30-year mortgage i
didn't get into it very smartly
but i have good equity in it and for
what i'm getting offered in this market
it is a very good deal and i'm going i i
found another place actually
30 minutes down the road in in another
town that
would still allow me to get to work
easily and
it is already a place that i have equity
in and with the equity i'm pulling out
of this place
would be able to put a significant down
payment on it get out of the pmi
uh then i also have my pickup
right now i'm uh i was upside down in it
and the market is going i'm sorry
you're gonna have to stop jake what is
it you need
um when i sell my house do i do i
invest into another house if i can get
good equity into it and get under the
pmi
or do i use it to pay off credit card
debt i've got 5 000 credit card debt and
some snap on tool debt
do i use that towards the debts there or
do i use that to get into another house
that i can be paying on
how much are you going to get out of
this house uh
approximately 35 a little over 35
000. and you're 24 years old and you're
single
yeah uh single but i have a seven month
old son
okay and um you make what a year
i make about 70 uh 75 to 78.
good for you okay all right
and you got 22 in tools and how much
other debt
uh 27 on my pickup which i think i can
sell and get out of get a cheaper
vehicle
and 5 000 in credit cards okay so if you
pay off the tools and the credit cards
you're renting right now
that would be correct if i did that yeah
you sell the truck and you build up your
emergency fund and then you build up a
down payment
and that's what i would do yes yeah i
know i would not i would not buy another
house right now
and let me just tell you um from a
business perspective
and knowing a tiny bit about your
business and
one of my best friends was in the
snap-on business for a while
those guys are
they are very very good at what they do
which is selling you tools and uh
that that line of i have to have these
tools to make my living
is partially true but it's not true of
22 000 worth some of that
was bought because you just wanted one
and in your world adding to that toolbox
unless it absolutely comes out of that
toolbox and causes your income to go up
more than the cost of that
tool sometime in the next 90 days is bs
yes sir people in your world
over buy tools yes sir
all the time it's not that you don't
need good tools the snap-on's good tools
it's good quality stuff
but they will sell you a line that y'all
you have to spend money to make money
and this is this is what you do your
craft with and all of those lines are
technically
true but it causes you to buy
a good 30 percent more than you need in
most people in your business and
subcontractors do it in the construction
business uh computer people do it
people in the video world do it they buy
a bunch of crap
and they you spend by a bunch of
equipment
and they spend all of their profits back
out in equipment and it's not stuff you
have to have to do business
we've talked about this before dave even
with women that i work with through
business boutique there's an element of
buying stuff whether it's equipment
supplies whatever
that we over buy because it somehow
justifies the business because it
somehow makes us feel like this
is real i'm really doing it i'm a real
fill in the blank
it's kind of like i used the example but
when i needed to go needed to go buy a
suit to interview for my first job out
of college like i didn't have interview
clothes and i just want to feel
like i've got a new suit i've got a new
computer back you don't need that to do
your job
and so when you start looking at when
you run your own business that that
money is coming out of your paycheck
because it's taking away from the
profitability of the business then you
start thinking how many tools do i
really need to have is this going to roi
or can i get by with with less and not
justify
the validity of the business with
purchases because what
justifies the validity of the business
is money yeah so here's the thing
you got 22 000 worth in your box you're
making 78
you probably don't need any more for a
while yeah yeah not gonna make mr
snap-on very happy yeah
but my goal is not to make him happy my
goals make you happy can you sell some
back you think
uh no but they're those guys are on a
route and so they'll swing by and see
him every so often and selling
we got a new thing you got to have this
you need this thing yeah and here's
what's happening with that
look what you could potentially make
with this yeah you you can
there's certain tools that you know a 70
year old version of it will actually
still work perfect
right right other tools need to be brand
new right
and so um but you just have to be
careful because that's the business that
they're in and they're very very good at
it
well and i would be willing but there's
an element of business analysis to this
where you go okay they
snap on tools salesman guy comes by and
he's like oh we've got this new thing
that does this new thing and you go
i don't have a request for that you
don't mean like the requests that i have
are oil changes the
brakes are bad i need new you know
rotors okay you got the tools for that
cool do
get the tools for the things you
actually use not the new widget that
someone's trying to sell you because you
don't have people coming in with that
doesn't matter
yeah oftentimes that's very very true so
be careful with that's all i'm warning
you on jake
but i think you're right you sell the
house you become debt free you sell the
truck you become debt free
get you a beater uh finish your
emergency fund up
uh then save your down payment and
that's probably a year to a two-year
process for you right now from today
but during that two years you're going
to be so unbroke
because you won't have any payments
right that it's going to be a wonderful
place to be
and you're carrying more stress maybe
even than you realize right now between
the credit card the tool debt the truck
and the house and when you step out of
all of that and you're just a renter
uh for a couple years and you say okay
by the time i'm 26 i'll be back into a
house and i'm paying a really good
strong down
payment no pmi and i won't have any debt
and it's completely different decision
making
than it is to doing it today yeah and
kind of what you're doing is you're
cutting halfway through the thing and
i'm just saying
cut all the way through it yeah cut all
the way through it yeah so good good
questions